all right everyone
what's going on i'm gonna wait a second
here to get everyone in
while people are joining before i forget
please smash the like button on this
video so more people on youtube will see
it
don't forget to subscribe to the channel
and don't forget that i write a
daily letter to over 50 000 investors i
basically cover business technology
uh finance and bitcoin can subscribe at
pompletter.com
all right people are starting to trickle
in here so
if you want to get more of this stuff go
subscribe at pompletter.com
smash the like button subscribe to the
channel and let's kick this thing off
the big news 52 million americans have
now lost their job in the last four and
a half months
uh obviously that is a unfathomable
number
um there's a whole host of different
reasons as to why 52 million of people
uh have lost their jobs but it
essentially breaks down to
there's a global pandemic that led to a
government mandated shutdown
of the economy and when that occurred uh
small businesses and large businesses
alike couldn't support
keeping those employees their revenue
basically went to
uh zero right in many cases and so
essentially what happened is the us
government stepped in
and they have something what that i call
bridge the gap stimulus so the whole
idea was
um there was a very abrupt disruption to
the u.s economy
and that was through that government
mandated shutdown and their idea was hey
this is going to last
for three to six months and so if we can
step
in with monetary stimulus and fiscal
stimulus and we can basically
pump up the economy we can put money in
the hands of the people who are going to
be hurt
we can do everything we can to kind of
prop up that economic data
we only have to do it for three to six
months and then those programs can
basically
end and by the time that those programs
are ending the economy will have been
turned back on
and kind of recovered and we'll be off
to the races again so you can kind of
think of this as a
inverted um drop right or kind of a v
where it drops down and then the belief
was that you were going to get that
v-shaped recovery
and the stimulus would merely bridge the
gap right and
kind of keep people living the same life
not suffering from that economic drop
now the problem is that many of those
monetary stimulus
um you know efforts uh in that package
are now running out so we're kind of at
the three to six month
range and as those programs expire it's
very
clear that the economy has not recovered
and so there's been 2.4 trillion dollars
of monetary stimulus so far
that's been presented in that includes
everything like the
paycheck protection program which was
hundreds of billions of dollars
lent directly to small businesses the
idea there was it's a low-cost loan in
the worst case scenario in the best case
scenario if you don't fire any of
your employees and you don't dock their
pay you then don't have to pay it back
so it's a forgivable loan if you kind of
follow all the rules
there's also a 600 weekly beefing up
of unemployment insurance so if you
applied for un employment insurance
you basically got what unemployment uh
traditionally would pay you plus an
additional six hundred dollars
uh that ends this week um coming up
and so july 31st is when that'll end the
ppp
loans uh those expire at the end of
september
where then businesses can go ahead and
they can actually start to fire
employees without getting docked
and have to be forced to pay back that
money so a lot of these programs are
rolling off here kind of at the end of
next week into the end of september
mainly because the government thought
that this would be over uh but it's not
and so now we've got kind of this really
weird situation where democrats have put
forward a
three trillion dollar stimulus package
right if you go back and remember what i
said in march right all the way back in
march i said
it's gonna take five plus trillion
dollars for them uh to kind of get
through this there's no way it's only
going to be one two three trillion
dollars so we've
done 2.4 trillion the democrats have a
three trillion dollar package that they
put forward
uh republicans don't like it uh
republicans have kind of gone back to
the drawing board
they're trying to keep it around one
trillion dollars
but reports are when they unveil that
package
in the early part of this coming week
it's going to look something like 1.5 to
2 trillion dollars now
as part of that package there's two key
things that that seem to be coming down
the pipe
the first is there will be more
unemployment relief
so you'll continue to apply for that
unemployment insurance there's 52
million americans who have done that for
the first time ever in the last four and
a half months
um but that unemployment will not come
with 600
it looks like the republican plan is
going to be somewhere more in the three
to four hundred dollar range
so they're really trying to get to about
70
of what you are getting paid at your job
can they get that to you through
unemployment insurance
both with the traditional allocation or
amounts
but also with the federal uh beefing up
um or kind of that additional capital
and so if it goes from you know kind of
uh 600
a week to three or four hundred dollars
it's still some relief but it's
obviously not the 600
that's going to expire the second thing
is that they're going to put more money
into the ppp program so small businesses
can continue to apply for that
now what we are starting to see is there
are
many companies who have started to lay
people off right i think it's one of the
largest oil companies in the united
states
they've uh proposed plans that they're
going to lay off like 20 or 30 000
people if i remember correctly
you also see um the airlines all saying
you know 20 30 000 people that they are
um kind of alerting saying hey look we
are going to do mass layoffs um kind of
in the fall
uh and so you should go ahead and quit
your job now uh or take kind of
unpaid leave or go find another job
and so it just feels like uh all of that
bridge the gap stimulus
uh they didn't bridge the gap it came up
short because the economy hasn't
recovered the coronavirus
uh whether you believe the numbers or
you don't uh it's very obvious that
there hasn't been a reopening of the
economy because of the coronavirus and
so
that's something to continue to pay
attention to uh i do not
believe that they're going to get a deal
done by the end of this upcoming week
it's a lot to ask and if they were to
get it done
if the republican proposal is 1.5
trillion dollars at the beginning of the
week
do not be surprised if it creeps to two
and a half to three trillion dollars by
the end of the week
kind of there's almost this balance
between the faster you want to get a
deal done
the more money that will get packed into
it uh and really that's because
it's easier to cave on things and if
you're going to cave on something you're
likely to cave on adding things
rather than caving on taking them out um
and so we saw that previously
uh in that first bill uh the original
proposal was like a trillion dollars
ended up being two trillion dollars
right
um and so don't be surprised if kind of
a 1.5 trillion dollar
proposal ends up turning into two and a
half to three trillion dollars
um and asked this is all going on
everyone's looking around saying wait a
second there's 52 million americans who
lost their job in the last four and a
half
months there's all sorts of stimulus
packages getting
um you know announced and executed why
is everyone getting rich
how is that happening how is the top 50
of americans getting rich we're seeing
the stock market explode
we're seeing housing all sorts of
residential home sales explode
and it's because there's a manipulation
of the economy right they're stuffing
liquidity into the market
uh if you look at in the housing market
for example the 30-year
fixed-rate mortgage hit an average
across the country 2.87
this past week so 2.87 30 year fixed
rate mortgage
well that is almost 100 basis points
lower than where it was a year ago
and so when you look at that number
there's cheap capital available of
course people are going to refinance
of course people are going to leverage
that cheap capital to go buy homes
and so it's just manipulation yes we are
in a recession
but they've done a bunch of things in
order to
provide cheap capital so there's still
some sort of economic activity happening
right there's all these anecdotes all
over
uh the internet where people are putting
their homes up for sale and they're
getting
four five six ten full price
offers sometimes all cash sometimes
higher
than full price the median home prices
have gone up in the united states this
year right which is just crazy to think
about during a recession
and then obviously the stock market is
just exploding now
here's what's really interesting about
the stock market so this week we have
amazon apple mcdonald's starbucks
a number of pharmaceuticals like merck
and eli lilly
all i think alphabet right all of them
are going to report
their numbers we're also going to get
the q2
gdp number this week coming up and so
these are
absolutely essential data points to
understand really what has happened
and so we've seen two things occur in
the
s p 500 40 percent of businesses
or i'm sorry the average loss in revenue
is 40 so far so out of the companies
that have reported
the average loss in revenue or drop in
revenue has been 40
yet 80 of the companies that have
reported
have beat wall street's expectations so
you get this really weird thing where
company everyone knows the companies are
going to make less in money but
if revenue dropped 40 percent stocks
should be tanking
except for the fact that wall street was
actually expecting worse numbers
and so the numbers are positive in light
of wall street's expectations
now this just goes to show once again
that wall street
analysts they do the best they can right
some of them are incredibly intelligent
it's really hard to do this stuff and
they're usually wrong and so
when you get 40 on average loss in
revenue but that is better than
the expectation of wall street you get
stock prices going up you get a bunch of
liquidity getting injected into the
market stock prices go up
and so this is all being manipulated uh
in various ways
so that you continue to see a stock
market that's bounced you know 50 plus
percent off the bottom
the nasdaq has hit all-time highs if you
look at the s p
it's down just a couple of percent year
to date and so this is an artificial
stock
market right there's no way that you're
telling me that a stock price is higher
today
than it was before the pandemic but
they're making 40 percent less revenue
how does that make sense and then when
you look at just a macro
economy level 35 drop in gdp
is expected 35
drop in gdp for q2 if that number comes
out
and it's actually only 30 don't be
surprised if there's a positive reaction
it means oh we thought it was gonna be
really really bad but it wasn't as bad
as we thought
and therefore people get excited and
stock market go up so it all
goes back to what are you anchoring on
what are you comparing these data points
to
and usually it's on estimations from
analysts or expectations
who put them in charge right and and
that's ultimately the problem is people
end up
looking at the short-term price
movements based on how did this come in
based on analyst expectations rather
than what is the holistic picture
of the economy if you said to somebody
there is going to be
an average 40 drop in revenue for s p
500 companies
there's going to be a 35 in q2 gdp this
year the beginning of january
and the stock market is going to hit an
all-time high people would have laughed
at you there's no way they would have
thought of that right
if they said that there was going to be
a global recession but yet
home prices were going to go up personal
savings rate was going to go up
personal income rate was going to go up
the average
um mortgage 30-year fixed rate was going
to go down
nobody would believe this stuff right
and again it's because
the federal reserve and the u.s
government looked at 2008-2009
and they said what was the playbook how
do we intervene in this market
and artificially inflate it so that we
can bridge the gap
how do we actually prevent or mitigate
damage
until the economy recovers well as we
know that there's going to be a day of
reckoning and that day of reckoning
one of two things happens either they
are able to bridge the gap they can
continue to put trillions of dollars
into the economy
and basically hold over or bridge that
gap until the economic data recovers
and we get back to a fully functioning
economy
with true velocity of money and kind of
capital
sloshing around in a more organic way
and then they can stop with all the
monetary stimulus or what's going to
happen
is that they're going to run out of
bullets right at some point you just
can't keep printing trillions and
trillions and trillions of dollars
and the economy won't have recovered and
so all of these artificially inflated
asset prices
are going to have to drop to meet the
reality on the ground of the economic
situation now when that happens is
anyone's guess
obviously if they do not come up with a
stimulus package
kind of this coming week and the week
after then you're going to have these
monetary stimulus packages that were
introduced back in march they're going
to start to end and you're going to get
that day of reckoning much
sooner if you get this stimulus package
which i believe will get
passed and again i think it's gonna be
somewhere in the two to three trillion
dollar range which will put us over five
trillion dollars total
if that occurs you're basically just
kicking the can down the road you're
continuing to inflate this
artificial asset prices and so we get in
a really really weird world
where you're going to have to eventually
pay for your sins and one of the sins
that we are
committing right now is we are printing
trillions of dollars and so we're going
to pay for that
three different ways the first way that
we're going to pay for it is at some
point the asset prices that are inflated
eventually they pop or they drop and
and there's all sorts of economic damage
that occurs to investors
who bought into these artificially
inflated asset prices
the second way that we pay for it is
there's actually going to be
incredible damage created by we are
propping up businesses in the private
sector
that should shut down there's a lot of
businesses that are bad businesses
right that if the free market was able
to operate those businesses would get
wiped out
they would go and the entrepreneurs and
the investors
would lose money but then we would get a
re-allocation of resources
and they would end up in the hands of
better run businesses
so the free markets not being allowed to
operate right now
and so it's basically if you go across
the board and look at a lot of the
businesses that are being propped up
they're not good businesses and if
they're not good businesses
then you don't allow the free market to
clear out the bad businesses to allow
those resources to then get reallocated
in a better business model or in the
hands of a better operator
entrepreneur so what occurs now is
that's the second way that we're going
to see damage is eventually those
businesses are going to end up going
under
right you're just prolonging the
inevitable and then the third is the
bottom 50 percent of americans are going
to get their wealth
and their savings absolutely ravaged
here
and if you think about what ends up
happening the wealth in a quality gap
is not a bug of the system it is a
feature
and it is because when you print money
in an inflationary system
people who own assets stocks
real estate gold bitcoin are you know
whatever type of asset the price of
those assets
goes up and the value of the dollar goes
down
right peter schiff i saw him tweet the
uh i think it was today or yesterday i
thought it was a really good
uh good point he said between 1790
and 19 and uh 1971
the price of gold basically oscillated
between 19 and 20 dollars
an ounce over 200 years
it literally was about a dollar
difference between the price of gold
all of a sudden in 1971
to today the price of gold has topped 1
900
that's not because gold got more
valuable it's because the dollar
is being devalued if you look at the
stock market since 1971
if you price it in dollars it looks like
a directional 45 degree angle up into
the right
if you price that same stock market in
gold all of a sudden it's basically flat
the stock market has not gained more
value it's the dollar that's being
devalued
so that is how investors who own assets
quote
make money it's because it will take
more dollars to buy that asset in the
future
rather than less dollars right so they
are acquiring
u.s dollar value but the people the
bottom 50
of americans who do not hold any assets
right they have
cash they live paycheck to paycheck and
they can't come up with 400
emergency payment right it's about 45 to
50 percent of americans own those stocks
they get live paycheck to paycheck can't
come up with an emergency payment of 400
those people see their wealth right
their savings although it's small
absolutely gets eroded away because the
purchasing power gets uh get gets eroded
away
and their check that they receive every
week
is worth less money although it's the
same dollar amount so they're getting
paid twelve dollars a week right or
twelve dollars an hour
um and that twelve dollars an hour ends
up being the same twelve dollars an hour
it was last year
and next year but yet twelve dollars an
hour
actually bought you more goods and
services last year it then it buys you
this year
and this year it'll buy you more goods
and services than it'll buy you next
year
so you're actually making less and less
money although your paycheck has the
same number on it
and so we are going to have this day of
reckoning you cannot print trillions and
trillions and trillions of dollars
without any sort of economic damage and
so the things to watch are
uh there's going to be a fed meeting
this upcoming week
i do not see in any world than moving
interest rates
up if anything they may go down into
negative territory that's a super
religious
uh topic there's a lot of people for all
kinds of different reasons that would
fight that
um so my guess is that it stays at zero
percent uh last time
jay powell said we haven't even thought
about thinking about
raising rates so to me there is going to
be throughout all of 2020 and into 2021
we're gonna stay at a zero rate
environment
and maybe possibly go into negative
territory so i don't think we'll see
that
i do think you'll see a lot of
commentary uh thoughts and ideas around
the monetary stimulus because that is
the only lever that they have left
is they're going to have to continue to
hit us with as
much of the drug of monetary stimulus to
keep the economy high
right use the example in the past of the
economy is basically
um a drug addict right there it's a
crack addict you got to keep getting a
hit
to stay hot that's what the economy does
the economy will not run
and cannot continue to operate in the
way that we want it to
without getting these shots of monetary
stimulus but the monetary stimulus
contingency
continues to be bigger and bigger and
bigger and bigger
and so ultimately what you're going to
see is you're going to see these
trillions of dollars in packages
you're going to see unemployment
benefits extended you're going to see
ppp money extended you i wouldn't be
surprised to see another stimulus check
directly to americans
right um there's democrats who want kind
of another 1200 bucks
uh trump has come out and said that he
wants something more than twelve hundred
dollars
who knows what it'll end up being but
you'll get another payment directly to
americans
uh and then on top of all of that what
you're gonna get is you're gonna get
earnings reports coming this week so
will the tech companies actually
outperform right will you see
amazon's revenue explode because
everyone's sitting at home ordering
things online
uh will you see apple are more and more
people buying stuff
facebook if all of a sudden time on site
and users exploded
will you actually see that translate to
additional ad revenue right we saw
twitter have one of their best
growth quarters ever and so i think that
the the technology companies continue to
outperform
uh in this sector it makes sense
everyone's sitting at home moving to the
digital world of course the digital
companies will
will uh do very well and then all of
kind of the non-digital companies or
non-digitally native businesses
they're getting destroyed right snp
companies average revenue down 40
percent
there will be people like in the airline
industry where revenue dropped 80 plus
percent and so i think you've really got
to unpack what are the sectors that
these companies are in how have consumer
behaviors change
how quickly will they come back and then
holistically what's that gdp number is
it above or below
35 contraction in the economy 35
contraction in a quarter is an
unfathomable number
52 million americans who lost their jobs
in 4.5
months unfathomable there's about 30
million americans who are on continuous
unemployment right kind of they continue
to draw unemployment
30 million americans there's about 155
million americans in the u.s workforce
30 million of them about one in five
americans who are in the workforce are
currently unemployed and pulling
unemployment insurance week after week
after week
this is absolute chaos yet the stock
market's up
and people are getting a crash course
and this is what happens in an economy
when the federal reserve and the us
government steps in they manipulate
asset prices
so we'll see how it ends before i start
taking questions here
um remember please smash the like button
so more people on youtube will watch
this please subscribe to the channel
and i will put here in the comments
i write a daily letter every single day
uh to about 50 000
investors um and if you want to get on
that list it's just pompletter.com so go
ahead and subscribe
uh and you'll get that email every
single day
uh please start asking questions here
the only other thing that
i had written down to talk about is
uh i'm very interested to see how the
virus numbers that are coming out uh in
a number of states right there's been
about a thousand reported deaths again
we'll caveat this whole conversation
around the virus with
i can't tell you what the real numbers
are i don't know if they're under
counting over
counting i have no clue i see the same
anecdotal evidence that other people see
of
the numbers being wrong or inaccurate
right there was a guy in florida who
died in a motorcycle accident
yet he's counted as a covid death but at
the same time in new york
there's a total number of deaths have
increased but
they don't understand where a lot of
those deaths are coming from so who
knows if the data is
uh under counting overcounting all i
know is we've got bad data we're making
bad decisions because we're counting on
that bad data
and so if the hospitalization numbers
that are growing in a lot of these
states
if those death numbers are growing what
does that mean are we going to go back
into some sort of soft
lockdown are we going to go into more of
a shelter in place across the economy
we don't know but that's gonna be
something to watch um so so keep uh keep
your eye on that
all right let me see if i can start uh
answering these questions just fire away
with as many questions as
you got and i'll do my best i'll stay on
for about 35 minutes and we'll try to
run through as many of these
um everyone is what are people doing
their stimulus checks yeah look
here's the craziest part of this entire
situation if you look on
robin hood for example when those
stimulus checks went out
there was very compelling data that
showed a lot of people
literally took their stimulus check put
it in robinhood and started buying them
so people were just
trading in the stock market and if you
look at when they did that
they basically got those stimulus checks
right at the bottom of the market
and so you've got all sorts of the
billionaires and hedge funds and wall
street
folks on television being like you know
scratching their heads people are
shutting down their hedge funds me like
i don't get it the market makes no sense
anymore
um you know people saying hey we're down
on the quarter right
how is the stock market rebounded fifty
percent yet people haven't made money
um in the hedge fund world well let's be
and it's because retail investors
all they knew was i just got some free
money and so they went and they put in
the stock market and they've ridden this
and
is it a kind of enthusiasm fueled run
absolutely in the kind of retail and day
trading space
but at the same time i would argue that
actually what retail is showing us is
they
better understand the market dynamics at
play
then the professional investors why the
professional investors are looking at
spreadsheets
and they're trying to estimate how much
is
uh this airline's revenue gonna go down
and what retail investors are saying you
see it all over the internet people are
like
dude the airlines aren't going away
right they're not going
uh we're never gonna not fly again and
so you can sit there with your
spreadsheet and try to time the market
do whatever
i just know that united airlines stock
went from 80 down to 20
seems like a good time to buy and all of
a sudden when it rallies they catch that
rally
right so you have to remember that just
like in the startup world in in silicon
valley we tell founders all the time
you can have the best team and the best
product but if you pick the wrong market
or the wrong time
you won't win right and there's a
million examples of this
but if you actually have an okay team
and an okay product
but you pick the right market at the
right time it will carry you you will be
super successful
same thing here in investing is you
don't even have to be
the best analyst you don't have to do
all of the kind of hardcore
spreadsheet work all you had to do was
understand
the stock market dropped 30 and that is
a pretty good drop
investors bought in the retail space and
as that stock market recovered
they benefited from it and so you could
argue that
both the professional investor and the
retail investor have never done this
before
no one's ever lived through a global
pandemic that is investing in these
markets
and so retail outsmarted the
professional investors but they were
optimizing for two different things
the professional investors were trying
to time markets and the retail investors
were simply getting exposure with free
money that they had recently gotten so
that's where we get where we are
um let's see what else we got here well
housing prices continue to inflate up in
a broader economic decline due to the
trend towards work from home and social
unrest in big cities
uh this is a great question um so
basically the way that i think about
this
is there's two two key components uh you
have the national averages
and then you've got very uh region or
city specific
so compare the home price uh in the
residential sector uh continues to go up
you have mortgage rates coming down like
i said 30-year fixed rate about 2.8
7 across the uh the country but then if
you look in somewhere like new york city
for example
there is a plethora of uh supply on the
market
and prices are falling very very quickly
and so
how do you kind of reconcile those two
data points well
some of it is people don't want to live
in in a place like new york city
uh because in the beginning of the
pandemic there was all sorts of
kind of fear around the virus it was a
hot spot it was it was going really
poorly
you get people who say look i just want
to be confined in an urban area i want
to move
somewhere else uh you also get kind of
the social unrest scare some people
and then you and on top of all of that
it's a very
rent-heavy city right so actually what
you end up getting is a lot of renters
and much less buyers in a city like new
york compared to other places
and so i think that you've got to kind
of look and say to yourself hey
am i as an investor looking to benefit
from the more macro
national average and trends or am i very
specific to a market so
san francisco and new york are much more
similar than let's say new york and the
national average
and so i think that's where people are
starting to understand that outside of
these major metros you're getting these
housing prices
uh inflating it's because there's cheap
capital and again remember it's a fixed
rate mortgage and so there's going to be
long-term
impact from a lot of these um these kind
of
things that people are doing right now
but again time will tell kind of how
long that happens
i have been on record as saying that
this work from home movement
it would not surprise me whatsoever if
you start to see two things
one homes that are being built right new
construction
in the u.s jumped almost 20 percent in
june now it had dropped because most
construction was shut down in
april and into may so it's easy to kind
of have a big jump
uh when you're coming off small numbers
but it was almost 20 jump in the month
of june and new construction in the
united states
a lot of that new construction people
are going to start actually saying
i only want to buy a home that has a
legit home office
right and maybe i actually need two
because myself and my significant other
we're both gonna work from home
now what does that look like i don't
know right as a kid i remember
my friends and my parents and houses
that we would look at whatever
they would have kind of these home den
offices right which was basically kind
of like a small room
uh it usually didn't have doors like
fully closed
uh and it was kind of like oh you can go
in there and do some work it wasn't
optimized for things like zoom meetings
phone calls
all that kind of stuff and so don't be
surprised if you start seeing homes
being built out with super legit
uh offices they're promoting promoting
or marketing the fact that hey
this is a home specifically built to
work and live in uh and then even
uh seeing things like audio at home
audio
um all kinds of video and you know av
type
um work being done in a home so that it
is optimized for
working from home uh and then again one
of the things that we don't know is are
we going to see kind of just one big
office or are we actually going to start
seeing homes that come with two home
offices
so that you can live and work in the
same place we'll see how that kind of
plays out
but i think that that is definitely a
trend that people are going to uh
to to um uh start benefiting from you'll
see it in new home construction
you may see renovations happening uh and
then on top of that anybody who's got
like an extra bedroom they may start
converting those to home offices and
as they market homes for sale that will
be a big uh
selling point um it's the fed they never
run out of bullets
that's definitely true in the sense that
they can always do more of the same
the question becomes and this is the
wildest thing that i'm going to talk
about today
is the the fed has historically always
said we have a two percent inflation
target
uh coming out of 2008 2009 they didn't
come close to it
uh right we kind of stayed under that
two percent uh in terms of the cpi
reported number the official number
now i've talked in the past about
there's a lot of studies that show
not everyone has the same inflation or
experience the same inflation
so if you kind of break down the
socioeconomic ladder into five
separate buckets the bottom 20 percent
in many cases there's reports that show
they may have been experiencing
eight to ten percent inflation coming
out of 2008 2009 crisis
now the official cpi number never hit
two percent but when you get kind of
eight to ten percent for the bottom 20
then obviously that's something we've
got to pay attention to so when the fed
can't run out of bullets they are now
talking about the dead uh the i think
it's the dallas fed president
came out and said that he actually is
not worried about inflation at all
he's not going to worry about until we
hit 2 or even
overshoot it a little bit there's a lot
of countries around the world
who have said oh it's okay if we go over
our
uh target and the next thing they know
they lose discipline and they end up
actually destroying their currency
hitting hyperinflation all kinds of bad
things
now i'm not claiming that's going to
happen in the united states but what i
am claiming is that the rhetoric
and the discipline that we typically are
able to plant a flag in the ground and
say
you know the united states is a leader
in this area is starting to decay away
right that rhetoric is starting to
actually be a little scary the
discipline you can see them starting to
do things that are not as disciplined as
they have been in the past
and so does that ultimately lead to some
sort of bad economic situation
history would tell us that yes it inches
us closer now
are they going to have some sort of
hyperinflation situation next three to
five years i personally don't believe
that's going to happen
i do believe that we will have inflation
and even see something over two percent
uh and definitely in the unofficial
numbers we could see 10 plus percent in
certain socioeconomic categories
but it's something to keep paying
attention to is why all of a sudden
are people at the federal reserve uh
talking about
overshooting the two percent target well
they understand they're printing
trillions of dollars that's what's going
to happen
and so again if you go back to the
framework to be an investor in this
market you don't have to be a genius
all you have to understand is the macro
structure of an economy
and the macro structure of an economy is
if we print tons of money and devalue
the currency asset prices will explode
and it we're literally looking at we're
right uh kind of on the cliff and we're
looking at
are they going to stop printing money or
are they going to continue if they let
these monetary stimulus
package uh programs from march run out
that means they would stop printing
money you'd receive a big contraction
the federal reserve's balance sheet
but that's unlikely right we know the
republicans are going to unveil
a monetary stimulus package at the
beginning of this upcoming week we know
the democrats put forward a three
trillion dollar plan previously
so we are looking at whether it's the
republicans or the democrats a trillion
to three trillion dollars in proposals
by the time they get these things
settled again i believe that we're gonna
see
you know call two two and a half three
trillion dollars in a package and so if
there's going to be much more monetary
stimulus coming down the pipe
it is likely that they will continue to
inflate asset prices
over the coming months and so a lot of
people saying hey the stock market's
had this you know incredible run uh
there's no way that this can continue
oh yes it can absolutely it can and
structurally if they continue to print
money you're going to see asset prices
explode
right and so i think that's something
that people have to understand to stop
looking at you know did the uh revenue
of a business go down
well of course it all went down there
was global pandemic the government shut
down the businesses but if there are
just pumping money into the economy
the actual fundamentals of the business
don't matter for short-term price
movements now again
where that balance comes back right and
this is i think where
the professional investors are
scratching their head saying what do you
what's going on here
is there's going to be a day of
reckoning where we shift from the macro
structure being more important than
fundamentals
to okay the macro structure is evolving
or transitioning back to
not as much money printing and the
fundamentals will become more important
on that point there's likely to be kind
of the pullback in prices
but again the macro structure is built
over a very long period of time that 45
degree angle in the stock market
if you zoom out over decades is because
of the inflationary nature of the
currency
so keep going uh people who are working
will start to complain why work 40 to 60
work
weeks 40 to 60 hour work weeks while
others essentially get a vacation for 70
of the pay ubi is coming so absolutely
we saw this back in march in april there
was plenty of employees who were going
to their employer saying dude just fire
me like i'm gonna make more money on
unemployment than here
but you've got to fire me and so i think
that we kind of already had
one whole um you know iteration of that
it would not be
surprising to see a second iteration of
that uh the the thing i'm less worried
about
is um kind of essential or these workers
complaining and asking to be fired
uh because we kind of already had the
first iteration what i think is more
important to pay attention to here is
essentially this beefed up unemployment
insurance is a very watered down poor
man's version of ubi
right it is the government supporting a
um tens of millions of americans
and then when this you get the stimulus
check i think they sent the stimulus
checks in the first round over 100
million americans
so about one-third of our population now
if they do a second one
again watered-down temp temporary
uh poor man's version of ubi so in a
world where 10 years ago we could never
imagine ubi coming to the united states
now we're actually inching closer and
it's almost like we're testing it
right we're we've got early iterations
and we're saying oh does it make sense
to call it unemployment insurance and
beefed up
what about if we call the stimulus check
they're testing the waters they're
seeing what works what's the impact how
much like all of these things
i have no doubt over the next 10 to 15
years we will have ubi implemented in
the united states right now whether you
call it universal basic income you call
it modern monetary theory
you call it something else right you
call purple cows whatever you want to do
all i know
is that the government is going to
continue to support citizens
more not less i don't agree with that
right i actually think that's like
horrible idea but that is what is likely
to happen because again it is in the
interest of politicians to continue to
give
more things to people because it sounds
good people like the safety they feel
like oh they're helping me
but it is absolute political suicide for
a politician to take this stuff away
later right
so you get in a really really weird
world where
i am incentivized to give you more
things not take them away
and the number one thing that i can do
that gets you all excited is i can give
you money
and now there's precedent for doing it
and so it starts in times of crisis
but again never let a crisis go to waste
right it would not be surprising to see
this become
something that isn't as temporary
something that is much more
um kind of permanent in nature and so i
absolutely think that ubi
modern monetary theory whatever you
wanna helicopter money whatever you
wanna call it
it's coming i don't know if it is like a
2020 implemented for the long haul type
thing
but over the next kind of three to five
years i think that we we start to see
the actual plans
uh being implemented and then kind of 10
to 15 years uh it's something that's
just
you know people who are growing up in
the workforce at that time they don't
know anything else they just have always
known that
the government will give you a paycheck
uh which is pretty crazy
and so uh yes real people need money to
survive if this continues to be riots
and revolutions
so here is one of the things that i know
will be
a very divisive issue so i'll just call
it out right now uh
again there is a um a difference of
opinion between people who believe that
the government should intervene
and should manipulate and artificially
prop up the economy
and people who believe that you should
let free markets reign and kind of let
the economy do what it's supposed to do
now those two groups are optimizing for
two very different things
right the group that believes that the
government should step in they're
optimizing for mitigating short-term
pain right they and the federal
reserve's job in some cases is to
look at jobs right is if people lose
their jobs in the short term then the
federal reserve feels like they're not
doing their job
and so now you get somebody who's
optimizing for short-term
decision-making
and worrying about long-term
implications later the other group the
free market group believes that
look there will be short-term pain but
over a long period of time
this is a better system it mitigates
damage long-term
and actually creates a more robust uh
kind of secure
sturdy economy over a long period of
time and so
both of those groups are actually right
right that's the part of the divisive
conversation that no one wants to admit
both groups are right if you want to
optimize for
short-term pain mitigation you should
allow the government to step in
and print trillions and trillions and
trillions of dollars and they should
stuff it in every nook and cranny in the
economy they should give money to
businesses they should give money to
individuals they should bail out local
state and
and the local and state governments they
should bail out every single corporation
they should do all that stuff right
that's how you mitigate short-term pay
but obviously there's a price to pay for
that stuff over a long period of time
so they're correct in if you want to
optimize for short-term pain mitigation
go ahead and let the the intervention to
happen on the flip side of that argument
the free market folks they're correct as
well
that if you allow the free market to
rain then you will have short-term pain
but you have a much
sturdier secure kind of sustainable
economy over a long period of time
so what ends up happening is when people
have this debate
you've got to ask them what are you
optimizing for are you optimizing for
short-term pain mitigation or
long-term uh sustainability the correct
answer in my opinion again in my opinion
is you should always optimize for
long-term uh sustainability
right you can do things in the short
term that can mitigate some of the pain
but there's going to be pain right it's
like saying to a business hey
you you raised money uh you have a
product that products not selling very
well
you're spending much more money than
you're making and you've now been doing
this over and over and over and over
again
at some point you got to shut down the
business you
spend more money than you make and you
gotta shut down the business
but if all of a sudden the government
steps in says no we're gonna give you
more money
right we're gonna give you more and more
and more and more money you can actually
prolong that business for much longer
you can artificially prolong it
so that now those resources those
individuals
all of that that capital ends up getting
sucked up
by an inefficient non-productive
business
if the free market allowed you to clear
out that business would people lose
their jobs absolutely
but then they would go and find jobs at
something that's much more sustainable
right
and again you have to look at what are
people optimizing for people who want
the government to intervene
optimizing for short-term pain
mitigation people who want the free
market to kind of take over
they're trying to optimize for long-term
sustainability both arguments are right
absolutely fine no problem with it you
just got to realize
what do you as an individual where do
you come out on that debate
not so much around should the government
intervene or not but what are you trying
to solve for you're trying to solve for
the short-term pain mitigation
or that long-term uh situation so
socialism for the rich they are showing
us that they generally do not work for
us they're about to buy up our assets
with our money
so this is by far uh probably the
biggest thing that people
miss in my opinion about all of this is
i've got a friend travis kling
who who said that um monetary stimulus
or
quantitative easing is just ubi for rich
people
right quantitative easing is just
universal basic income for rich people
and what that means is when you print a
bunch of money and you inflate asset
prices what you're doing is you're
bailing out the rich
but when you bail out the rich everyone
looks at the asset price inflation and
they know the top 50
of americans own those assets so it's
very clear that you couldn't
bailed out the rich but the flip side of
that and
a really important point is inflation
like that through this quantitative
easing is a massive
hidden tax on the bottom 50 percent
and so what you're literally getting is
the rich are getting richer faster
and the poor are getting poorer faster
and so this socialism for the rich
it's not just socialism for the rich
it's actually socialism for the rich
and a punishment for the poor and so
what we are seeing
is a government that is optimizing
specifically
to bail out the rich and punish the poor
and they come at it with oh we gave you
1200
okay you gave the the people 1200 but
there's the billionaires in the united
states made over
half a trillion dollars so far
half a trillion dollars during this
crisis they've gotten richer i think
it's like
like just over 500 billion dollars how
is that possible
well it's because they're getting bailed
out by the government because the
government is printing so much money and
they're inflating asset prices
so socialism for the rich punishment for
the poor
that is what is going on people can
debate whatever they want but at the
core
that is how we get in a world where
there's a massive wealth inequality gap
and again i go back to that's not a bug
of the system that is a
feature now what you at home can do is
you have to get educated right
you've got to understand how the system
works so that you can position yourself
so one that you're protected so you
don't want to be punished with the poor
and then you want to position yourself
so you can benefit with the rich
right why is it that the rich people
aren't walking around with all cash
well it's because they understand by
owning assets that's how you continue to
build wealth
well why are all the poor walking around
with a hundred percent of their wealth
and cash
not being able to pay for or living
pages to paycheck it's because
they haven't been able to save the money
and invest it in order to get out of
that situation
right that is a structural issue now
i've got a whole bunch of ideas as to
how we actually solve that issue
but if you are sitting watching this
right now you've got to understand
this is the system that i'm in here's
the rules of the game if i want to win
this game
i've got to use the rules to my
advantage i can't sit around with cash
because that's going to get devalued uh
today and in the coming years
and i've got to get into assets where
the asset prices are going to get
inflated
what those assets are we can get into
kind of all the details there but that
ultimately is what is
is going on um all right keep asking
your questions
uh and um smash the like button
subscribe to the channel
i'll put this in here again if you want
more of this content on a daily basis
please subscribe to uh the email that i
send every single morning
50 plus thousand investors end up
reading it
i put it i typed it wrong because i'm an
idiot so
if uh you can go subscribe and i will
uh send you an email every morning uh
what other questions here
uh trade your fraudulent fake dollars
for silver
gold and bitcoin and then ignore the
propaganda uh
yep so basically uh let's talk a little
bit about inflation hedge assets right
so real estate
gold silver and bitcoin um when i look
at this
these are some of the most attractive
assets to me right now right and why
is that so again when you look at the
gold price it went from twenty dollars
to one thousand nine 900 all because the
dollar has been devalued
bitcoin this year is up 30 35 it's the
best performing asset class
uh in the us this year why it's because
the dollar is being devalued right
bitcoin hasn't
changed at all right there was the
having but nothing's really changed with
bitcoin the dollar is being devalued
asset prices are being inflated
so ultimately i think that the four
really interesting
uh assets to look at real estate gold
silver bitcoin
now me am 32 years old
i have an incredible uh risk tolerance
and i have in my head a very specific
amount of my wealth that i'm willing to
lose to go to zero
right and so i choose to take that
risk capital that high percentage of
risk capital
because of my age because of my
lifestyle because of my risk tolerance
and i choose to invest in what i believe
out of those four assets is going to be
the highest performing
uh of them which is bitcoin right so
kind of paul tudor jones uh famously in
the last couple of months decided to
take two percent
of his assets and put it in bitcoin and
in the letter where he talked about it
he said
the reason why i am doing that is
because i believe that bitcoin will be
the fastest horse
in this category right and kind of the
inflation heads assets so
real estate will go up gold will go up
silver will go up but bitcoin will go up
more than all of them
mainly because it's the smallest market
cap so it's only about 200 billion
dollar market cap today
and it's hyper volatile so when
volatility works against you
and drawdowns right bitcoin dropped down
50 percent in a single day earlier this
year
gold dropped 12 to 15 equities down 30
um and kind of real estate uh kind of
stayed really flat frankly
um but now also when you go back up and
and you get the inflation of asset
prices
gold's up you know 20 or so uh you're
going to see equities up right
but now all of a sudden what you're
going to see is bitcoin is the best
performer because it's the most volatile
it's the smallest market cap
and so that's what i've chosen to do
with my wealth and why i've chosen to do
that
is because gold silver real estate and
bitcoin are all inflation hedge type
assets but i believe bitcoin will
outperform the rest this is not
financial advice there's risk go do your
research but that's why i've chosen to
take
a percentage of my wealth and do that
again i'm 32 years old i've got high
risk tolerance i'm willing to lose the
money that i've put in
so that is kind of how i think about it
now when you look at those other asset
classes
right when it's real estate and precious
metals precious metals are doing pretty
well this year it gold's up by 20
and i believe it's going to continue to
go up right i just don't think that
you're gonna see
a four thousand dollar gold price in the
next two years right
i could be wrong i would i would love
for all of my friends who are gold
investors
to be wrong and for there to be a four
thousand dollar gold price i just don't
see that happening
i see gold continuing to kind of grind
up and maybe i i think uh back in like
march or april i said that i could see
gold hitting kind of
2000 to 2500 over the next two years i
still kind of think like
that's a pretty good target for gold to
get to but maybe i'm wrong and i
underestimated and it
goes higher but but i do think kind of 2
2 500
would be interesting now when it comes
to real estate we're seeing residential
home prices go up
right now doing something like buying
real estate manhattan
some of the prices of the real estate is
actually all-time lows
right or or in kind of local lows not
all-time lows but local lows
and so what that means is there's been
this massive sell-off in prices
and so people who are have the capital
base can come in be opportunistic
being uh intelligent about how they buy
and where they buy and what they buy
they're gonna end up making a lot of
money over the coming years remember
when you make investments in real estate
majority
of the returns you will receive is based
on the price
that you pay at the time you buy it
right if an asset is worth a million
dollars
and you pay 950 000 you bought it for 50
000
less than it's worth if you bought it
for a million five
fifty thousand you paid fifty thousand
dollars more but if we buy
the same asset and i buy it at seven
hundred thousand and you buy it at nine
hundred thousand
of course i'm gonna make more money i
bought better than you did right so the
price you buy the asset at is gonna be
that one of the major determinations of
what's the actual return uh financially
you're gonna get out of that asset well
if asset prices are down
there's nothing that has changed with
the assets in new york uh
in terms of the actual assets themselves
over the last five months now
demand has shifted and because demand
shifted prices drew down
but if you believe that people want to
live in new york city over the coming
uh you know decade or two and that
actually is going to return to more
normal levels and even potentially go
higher then of course buying at low
prices would be a smart decision
now if you believe that you know new
york's over no one wants to live in new
york anymore
uh this whole virus and pandemic thing
is gonna get everyone out of
um uh kind of urban areas and uh all of
those people are gonna move out and
demand actually be lower in 10 years
than it is now
then maybe buying here is not a good
idea but that's the type of calculation
you've got to look at and so i think
that
um real estate specifically i see a lot
of people saying hey i want to go get
into real estate right now
because i see prices down the price you
pay is going to determine the return
that you get
and so you got to be smart about the
macro trends right is the place that
you're buying
it something that you see demand being
higher or lower in five to ten years
and then what's the price that you're
paying and then look the other thing is
use the financial incentive there's a 30
year fixed rate mortgage national
average of 2.7
it's 100 basis points lower than it was
a year a year ago you have access to
cheaper capital
of course there's people who are gonna
be excited about that and they're gonna
use it to their advantage so
i think that people should absolutely um
go ahead and take it take advantage
uh bill pulte what's up man if you guys
aren't following bill on
uh on twitter you should absolutely be
following bill pulte he's doing a
fantastic job i see him here in the
comments
um let's see what uh what other
questions do uh do people have
um if you're ju if we're judging value
of these assets against dollars what's
the point at what point do you want
dollars when they keep devaluing
so manuel that's a great example a great
point which is
um again if you go back to the stock
market since 1971
and you say okay the stock market is
priced in dollars it's up a lot if you
price the same stock market in gold it's
about flat just a little down
if you do it in bitcoin since 2011 it's
down uh significantly
and so it's all about what is the asset
being priced in dollar is obviously the
global reserve currency and so everyone
chooses to do that
um and it ultimately is going to be
something where
how do rich and wealthy people get rich
and wealthy they
buy assets and they hold them for very
very long periods of time
right there's basically two strategies
so this is actually an important point
there's two strategies to get rich
in the united states all right well
three you can inherit money but
none of us can control that so throw
that out the window the two things that
you can do
to become wealthy in the united states
are one you can
buy assets that are priced in dollars
and hold them for very long periods of
time
and when that happens those assets will
actually increase in value
because the dollar is being devalued so
whether it's again real estate gold
stocks bitcoin whatever it is over very
long periods of time you'll almost get
this like 45
degree angle straight up into the right
uh because the dollar is being devalued
in a very kind of
um intentional about one and a half two
percent a year and that's what drives
that price inflation
so that is one way is get out of cash
get assets hold them for a long period
of time
the second thing you can do is invest in
innovation so
the most innovative companies in the
world drive the most returns
right again innovation leads to
financial returns
now there's two ways to do it public
markets and private markets right
public markets there ends up being a lot
of people who make a lot of money by
investing in something that's innovative
and the stock
price goes up but the susceptibility
that people have
is that they end up selling if the price
doubles or triples so they buy a stock
let's say it's trading at you know 50
bucks
it goes to 100 they sell or they buy it
at 50 bucks and it goes 150 bucks they
sell it
well all of a sudden that stock over
10 years goes from 50 to
and they don't hold it for a long period
of time because in that case liquidity
actually can serve as a detrimental
thing right the fact that you have the
liquidity
means that human nature can take over
you feel great you just made a bunch of
money and so rather than press your
winners meaning that it goes from 50 to
100 and you invest more
you goes from 50 to 100 and you sell
right and then you miss majority of the
of the increase in value but innovation
drives returns
now in the private market the
illiquidity actually serves as a benefit
in many cases right
if you go and you talk to an angel
investor and you say hey you invested in
uber at a 5 million valuation when it
was worth 50 million dollars would you
have sold
with hindsight bias they say no
absolutely not i knew it was going to be
a multi-billion dollar company
ah you made 10 extra money are you sure
you wouldn't have sold what if when it
was trading at
500 billion or 500 million dollars and
you had made 100 x
would you have sold no no i never would
have sold no no way
i don't know right and so when you then
kind of look at it as it goes up and up
and up and up
at what point would they have sold if
there was liquidity there's very few
people who could have
held from five million dollar valuation
up to
you know whatever it was 40 50 billion
dollar valuation and so the illiquidity
actually serves as a
benefit in those scenarios so you've got
to be able to understand
if i want to be wealthy what are the two
things i can do buy assets priced in
dollars hold them for long periods of
time
and allow kind of the structural system
to actually drive my returns rather than
me be the genius
or i can invest in innovation public or
private markets
and i've got to be right and i've got to
be early in order to capture significant
upside
what do most people do they say well why
don't i just do both why don't i take a
percentage of my portfolio put it into
assets allow that system to kind of not
get rich quick but get rich for sure
and allow the structure of the system
just to make me wealthy over many
decades
at the same time i'm going to invest
some percentage usually a smaller
percentage of my net worth into
innovation
that could be through venture capital
private equity public markets whatever
it is
and then that's where you try to to
really hit kind of outsized returns
so that's how these portfolios are built
go look at all of the
wealthiest people in in the country
that's basically what they did
now they supercharge that strategy with
an additional thing which is
the innovation that they invest in
normally is innovation that they're in
that they own right so they own equity
in their own business
and the reason is because rather than
put a couple hundred thousand dollars
into something you know a very small
percentage they say i'm gonna
create this value and i'm gonna own a
very high percentage of it right whether
it's majority or
a large minority position and that's how
they create wealth
and so ultimately if you understand
those two things you can position
yourself to be wealthy um all right what
other questions uh
what other questions do we have here um
people are asking
i just see a bunch of questions about
bitcoin um basically the whole idea
behind bitcoin is
so far uh it's up like 30 35 this year
it's the best performing asset
um or asset class uh it's you know
stocks are essentially flat
uh you've got gold that's about twenty
percent bitcoin up thirty thirty five
real estate um in many markets is
trending upwards but but still bitcoin
is outperformed
and uh in june of 2019
right so let's go back this is this is
my uh victory lap a little bit
this is me uh with my internet receipt
so in june of 2019 i wrote a piece
that said i believe that we are heading
into a scenario that is going to be
rocket fuel for bitcoin and that
scenario it needed three things to occur
we needed a significant decrease in
interest rates we needed large printing
of money
and we needed the bitcoin having in may
of 2020
to execute correctly we've got all three
of those things that have happened
i did not believe that we would see zero
percent interest rates
or that we would see two emergency cuts
to drive interest rates to zero
i did not believe that we would get
trillions and trillions of dollars of
monetary stimulus
but i did believe that we would get the
bitcoin having to execute successfully
so i thought we'd get a drop in rates
not zero but a drop and i'd see printing
of money but not trillions of dollars
so really what's happened here is we've
gotten a way bigger drop than i thought
we've gotten way larger amount of money
printed
and we had the successful bitcoin having
there could not be a better scenario
over the next 18 months for bitcoin to
be walking into
i believe it is absolute rocket fuel for
bitcoin's price
because you have a macro environment
that is providing
all of the ingredients for this asset
to explode in u.s dollar value right
again it is the most volatile of all
assets
and therefore because of that volatility
when it goes
down it works against you when it goes
up and you're long it works for you
and so that's my entire thesis around
bitcoin
is that we are going to see an absolute
explosion in the u.s dollar price
right i'm on record again there's risk
do your research this is not financial
advice but i am on record saying
uh back in january i believe it was that
we would see bitcoin go
from at the time about ten thousand
dollars to over a hundred thousand
dollars by the end
of december 2021 so the end of next year
seeing a bitcoin price of a hundred
thousand dollars or more today we said
about 9 500
right so that's kind of where i think
everything's going we'll see what
happens there
um but i think it's very very
interesting um okay there's a question
about
would you say a young person starting
their career should mostly do high risk
high return
investments like crypto tech stocks etc
so
i think that there's two things that
young people should do right and
the way that i would do this is uh if i
was going back let's say i was 20 i
actually have a brother who who's about
22
23 year or maybe 24 years old at least
24 years old uh and so at 24
um we just went through this exercise
and we were talking about all the
different investments that he could make
and what i said to him was i said listen
the amount of capital you have right now
is going to be immaterial in your life
right it's nowhere near what you're
going to have in the future
and so today you should take as much
risk as possible with that capital
because it is likely that if you lose it
it won't matter over the long run
and if you're right it actually could
grow into something important right and
actually be meaningful in your life
now as part of that as you get older you
should start to go from 100
high risk zero percent um kind of low
risk
to maybe you go eighty percent high risk
twenty percent low risk right and so
kind of there's a continuum as you get
older and older could be
you go from your early to mid twenties
to your late twenties right and now you
say hey look i'm actually thinking about
getting married i don't think about
starting a family or i've got other
things that i want to worry about buying
a house
uh you know traveling whatever then
maybe you start to say okay you know
what i'm gonna take 20
of that uh high-risk capital previously
and start diverting that 20
to an s p and let it compound over time
right but
right now when you're 22 23 24 years old
or even in
18 or younger right there's a whole
group of people that will say
oh you should let compounding work for
you you should let the stock market have
eight percent
kind of uh annualized um compounding
work for you
absolutely but i am of the belief that
you have to invest in innovation in
order to drive financial returns
and there's a way to get rich but
there's a difference between rich and
wealthy right and being
rich just means that and this is gonna
sound crazy right but in america
being rich is like having a million
dollars when you uh when you retire
right that's great most young people
when you're looking at it and you've got
a couple hundred dollars a couple
thousand dollars you say wow if i had a
million dollars i'd be rich
in the grand scheme of things having a
million dollars is not that much money
in today's society
right a million dollars today when you
fast forward
five ten years from now is going to be a
lot less because again
if it's in cash the purchasing power of
a million dollars is gonna deteriorate
significantly so a million dollars may
seem like a lot today but five or ten
years from now a million dollars is
going to be worth
much less and so what you've got to be
able to do is
you've got to understand do i want to be
rich or do i want to be wealthy
and if you want to be rich let
compounding go to work for you right but
if you want to be wealthy
and i'm talking about tens of millions
of dollars and you're young
the way to do that is to invest in
innovation so you can take capital and
you can deploy it into highly innovative
things
most young people actually have a better
understanding of what is innovative than
older people right if you went you
talked to a lot of young investors
um kind of you know two years ago and
you said hey is electric cars gonna be a
thing in the future
they'd be like duh every car is gonna be
electric right or if you ask them
uh what about cash app and square right
they'd be like of course like i use that
all the time with my friends
so there's all sorts of things that
young people understand because it's
part of their daily life
that older people have a hard time
analyzing and kind of identifying
so you know the things that are
innovative by investing there you can
drive
outsized returns the second thing you
can do as a young person is
get started early right so again the
number
one way to get wealthy in the united
states is to own equity in things
whether you're an investor or you're the
builder
why not do both invest capital and start
a business
that business doesn't have to be a
venture scalable uh
venture capital type business where you
got you raised millions of dollars and
it's got to be the next you know
facebook or instagram or google or
twitter or whatever you can have a great
business
where literally it throws off half a
million dollars in cash a year
in terms of net owner earnings and if
you invest that capital correctly you'll
be worth tens of millions of dollars
by the time you're in your 40s and 50s
so you don't have to necessarily hit
grand slams
you can hit singles doubles and triples
and it's all about the cash flow in
those businesses rather than the
um equity value right so i think that
there's a whole bunch of things that
young people can do
i tend to think that the idea of
diversification is horrible advice right
if you talk to a warren buffett for
example
um he him and charlie munger on record
is saying that uh diversification is for
people who don't know what they're doing
right and concentration builds wealth
diversification protects wealth
right so if you don't have money going
and being in a highly diversified
portfolio that's going to make you
between five to eight percent annualized
at 18 to 22 years old is stupid it's
literally stupid
and anyone who tells you that's what you
should do doesn't understand how to
actually build wealth
right if instead they said to you you
should go and um
do a lot of research and work and either
create a business where you've got
highly concentrated
uh net worth in a single asset and grow
that asset or
you should make investments and things
that you think are highly innovative
that you've done the work right
analyze the risk and if you're right it
will grow
that concentration is what's going to
build your wealth the diversification
later when you have money that's where
you'll actually end up protecting it so
i think that you've really got to
to understand that um i see people
asking where plina is
uh she literally is taking a nap right
now uh probably because she knew i was
gonna come through this and didn't want
to be annoyed
um all right i'm gonna take uh five or
six more questions here what else uh
what else do you guys have um yes jeff
bezos
almost doubled his wealth after he gave
his wife uh like 30 billion dollars
right
if you understand that i mean that's
insane he's the wealthiest guy in the
world and he gave his wife
or ex-wife i guess at this point 30
billion dollars um absolutely
uh nuts um people like to look rich more
than they like to be wealthy don't be
that
uh marlo yeah look this is one of the
things there's a picture i've talked a
bunch of times about
um of jay-z that's not that floating
around the internet and basically
uh there's two pictures of jay-z one of
them on the left is
uh jason's got all the chains and the
earrings and you know all
kind of the the symbols of wealth a big
watch all that kind of stuff
and it says jay-z net worth 100k and
then on the right side of the image it
has jay-z and just a black t-shirt with
a blazer on
and it says jay-z net worth 100 million
dollars and
throughout my entire life the richest
people i know
don't act like the richest people right
and it's because they understand
why do i need all the flashy flashy
things now do they spend money
absolutely they got a lot of it right so
they'll do things they'll buy a nice car
they'll buy a nice house they'll do all
that stuff
but what i mean is they don't do it over
and over and over and over again right i
i've got friends who literally will say
hey this year i'm going to make five
million dollars and
i promised myself every year that i hit
a five million dollar target i'm gonna
buy myself a nice car
and i have a budget up to 250k a lot of
people say wow you're buying you know
250 000
car well they made 5 million so actually
on a percentage basis like
that's pretty cheap in terms of a small
amount of capital i've got friends who
they make
150 000 and they literally spend a
hundred thousand dollars every year on
nonsense
right and social how do you do that once
you take taxes out and all this kind of
stuff well they end up going into debt
and so what you have to realize is
it's all relative there is no kind of
one simple
uh you know uh silver bullet for all
this stuff but there are many lessons
over history that have shown people how
do you build wealth how do you
accumulate that wealth and then how do
you actually make sure
that it's something that will continue
to grow over long periods of time
and you don't have to worry about uh any
government forget just the u.s
government any government
eroding away your wealth and savings by
just printing money like they're doing
um all right two more questions let's
see uh
robotics uh yeah so here's the thing and
i see people talking about ark and kathy
would know them so
as many people know i've interviewed
kathy wood from arkanvest twice on uh
on the podcast uh she's probably one of
my favorite investors on wall street
because she understands that's where
innovation leads to returns um
i personally have a very deep conviction
in robotics uh
mainly for two reasons one is uh the
virus has shown us that we're gonna have
to nationalize
uh not nationalize in terms like the
government take over but we're gonna
have to bring back
a lot of supply chains and manufacturing
facilities to the united states
if we do that cost will go through the
roof because american labor is so
expensive
and so it is going to have this
resurgence in 3d printing robotics
all sorts of different things that can
help continue to drop
the price of manufacturing and supply
chains here in the u.s so we have to
have a resilient supply chain and
manufacturing industry but it's going to
take robotics and
and all sorts of things there to
continue to drive that price down so
that people can still keep the profit
margin than they currently have so i'm
very very interested and excited about
kind of all of the things we're going to
see in 3d manufacturing
and robotics that is just one
application of it
and ultimately yes will people lose
their jobs because of robotics and 3d
printing
absolutely but i believe that what ends
up happening
is that those people then go find more
productive work to do
so the example that i always use is at
one point it was like 98
of all uh people in the united states
were farmers
right well obviously we got much better
at the food supply chain
uh technology all that kind of stuff now
it's about two percent i believe
is uh is farmers the united states well
what happened to all we lost all the
jobs
yeah but those people went and they
found much more productive things to do
with the industrial revolution like look
look at the country and the economy that
we built right and so i think that
that's the same thing that happens here
is we'll just continue to get more and
more people
who will um go find more productive work
to do i don't get so caught up on
um you know people losing their jobs
because of technology
ultimately technology is very
deflationary right my friend jeff booth
wrote a book about this
essentially the idea is that as
technology continues to become more
prevalent
you get deflationary trends at play so
the cost of things goes down and you
kind of free up that labor to go do
other more productive things
um all right do you think real estate
prices will drop with forbearance
expiring
in september uh i think oh there's
blender right there pliny just woke up
from her nap
no i didn't for anyone who is uh who is
interested
i got some i got some friends in the
chat i was chatting with them
all right okay i'll let you i'll let you
go that's plainest way of telling me to
shut up
uh no so i think that uh yeah if you
were saying hey plenty miss pomp
um all right so oh hi pelino welcome the
main host
all right so the whole idea around real
estate prices essentially is um
yes there is going to be uh potentially
uh this situation
that uh forbearance will go away people
will actually
kind of get hurt by that uh real estate
prices go down but
if there is still cheap capital in the
market i believe that we could continue
to see kind of propped up real estate
prices
the other piece of the real estate uh
analysis that uh
needs to be uh talked about and paid
attention to is
uh there's a very big shortage of u.s
new housing that comes on the market
every year so the numbers that i
recently saw
were about 200 000 to 250
000 homes uh is the deficit that we have
so there's basically here's the demand
that we have for new uh homes in the us
and here's what we actually produce
that deficit or difference is about 200
to 250
000 homes right so it's about the size
of a city like miami
that's how many homes more we would have
to produce on top of what we already do
just to keep up with demand
and so if you continue to have this
housing shortage uh you've got a lot of
kind of um
margin for error in terms of um the
demand so demand could drop but because
there's that housing shortage
you actually could continue to have more
demand than supply and therefore prices
at least sustained if not continue to
rise
you have cheap capital network rate
again i'm much more kind of a macro
um analysis type person where i want to
understand what are the big forces or
trends at play
so that i don't have to pick the perfect
stock i just have to do asset allocation
and i think that's the key piece that
retail misses a lot i spent a lot of
time with institutional investors and if
you ask most of these cios that run
multi-billion dollar books
um what they'll tell you is the returns
that we get
it doesn't come down to like did we pick
the right stock or not or even in many
cases do we pick the right manager or
not
it's actually our asset allocation so
did we decide to put
five percent or 25 percent of our uh
assets in commercial real estate or in
private equity or in public equities or
in precious metals or whatever it is
that asset allocation is going to be the
biggest decision in terms of what
returns you actually end up driving
and so that's the part that as a retail
investor individual you got to back up
and look at the whole thing
say okay how am i allocating my assets
how much is in public equities versus
somewhere else how much is in real
estate
then once you get into the asset class
uh do you
do low-cost indexing do you pick stocks
do you go with a manager
all of those other decisions can help
improve or potentially slightly hurt
but there's very few managers that if
the public's uh equity market is 15
there's very few managers that are gonna
throw up a two percent uh performance
or there's very few managers they're
gonna throw up 40 performance
right so if the public equities are
generally going to be 15
this year right now i'm just making up a
number uh then most managers are going
to oscillate between like 10 and 20
percent
so you're directionally going to be
correct just by the asset allocation
decision
uh and then the micro decision you make
can kind of hurt or improve that just a
little bit
same thing with other asset classes as
well and so i think the asset allocation
is much more important to look at
again i think real estate is super
interesting right now uh mainly because
i see
tons and tons of money printing already
happening i think there's going to be
trillions of dollars on the way
i do not see this slowing down and so i
think people just got to buckle up
get out of cash get into these inflation
hedge assets um and be prepared to
uh let the structure of the economy end
of the financial system
and and use your knowledge of how money
actually works
to your advantage that you're positioned
to build wealth rather than
try to be a gambler right kind of all
the day trading all stuff there's people
who are good at it
i'm sure people get lucky at it it's not
my game i don't think i have an
advantage there um but but i do believe
that uh people can definitely
um you know benefit in the time of
crisis like this if they understand that
the macro environment
so all right that's it for today i need
a huge favor from each one of you
i need you guys to go right now smash
the like button on this video if you
learned anything during it so that more
people on youtube see it
please subscribe to the channel and then
i'm dropping every single morning
i write a letter to over 50 000
investors where i
essentially break down business
technology finance and bitcoin
and i do my absolute best to educate
people
uh using my personal opinion and my
analysis of what's going on in the world
so
use pompletter.com again pompletter.com
go there sign up you'll get the email
you'll learn some stuff
you can reply and get i read every
single one
try my best to respond to everybody it's
awesome uh
and so i hope you guys enjoy that uh yes
miss
plana marinova pompliano or plana evilo
marinova pompilano
thank you for allowing us to do this i
will let her know um
miss pomp rocks but she sleeps a lot
that is very very very true
uh all right that's it for today thank
you guys so much smash the like button
subscribe to the channel go subscribe at
pompletter.com
and i will try to do this again in the
future thank you guys so much